[Música]
quando eu era adolescente eu usava
aquelas agendas que iam ficando gordas
ao longo do ano porque ali aguardava o
papel do sonho de valsa que eu tinha
ganhado do menino bonitinho da escola
os ingressos para assistir embalos de
sábado à noite que eu ainda não tinha
idade para ver mas o porteiro do guarujá
fazia vista grossa ea gente aproveitava
e guardava também qualquer bobagem que
eu achasse que era muito relevante para
as minhas memórias eu também usava essa
agenda para escrever sobre os meus
sentimentos sobre os meus paqueras e aos
15 anos a minha primeira paixão foi um
fracasso
eu fiquei arrasada e aí eu descobri que
escrevendo sobre isso a minha dor ea
diminuindo depois com a vida
profissional eu parei de escrever e eu
fui recuperar a escrita na porta da
escola do meu filho eu é que tive uma
longa carreira como na área de marketing
quem é da área sabe que a gente tem que
fazer uma entrega total não tem tempo
pra nada
e obviamente eu deixei muitas coisas de
lado uma delas foi escrita e um dia
nessa minha vida louca a babá do meu
filho me ligou e falou que não poderia
buscar na escola ela teve alguma coisa
urgente para resolver itabom tô indo lá
e quando eu cheguei o marcos saiu e na
hora que ele me viu ele esperava
encontrar babá como todos os dias na
hora que ele me encontrou ele teve uma
reação que pra mim foi tão inesperada
ele começou a falar essa é a minha mãe e
ele cutucava todo mundo que estivesse a
volta ele puxava o paletó do porteiro
puxava o avental da recepcionista o
braço da mãe do big e falava essa minha
mãe
essa minha mãe as pessoas não entendiam
o que ele estava querendo dizer mas ele
não se importava ele só queria falar
para a escola inteira
a mãe dele estava lá porque as mães dos
amigos pegavam as crianças diariamente
mas ele sai até hoje inclusive às três
horas da tarde como é que você larga uma
empresa para buscar uma criança às três
horas da tarde e aquela reação dele me
tocou muito e eu falei eu preciso
colocar isso no papel
na verdade não era bem mais papel porque
eu escrevo tudo no meu telefone
isso virou um texto que publiquei no meu
facebook que eu pouco usava na época
e aí os meus amigos amaram e se
emocionaram outras mães se identificaram
e aquilo foi me me dando inspiração para
escrever mais porque eu adoro observar o
comportamento das pessoas
eu sou aquele tipo de pessoa que escuta
a conversa da mesa do lado no
restaurante portanto cuidar da e aí eu
juntei o meu o meu olhar observador com
a minha paixão pela escrita e
transformei isso nas minhas crônicas de
comportamento e passei a publicar essas
crônicas com uma certa freqüência e
descobrir que o que me dá o verdadeiro
prazer na vida é ver a reação das
pessoas é descobrir se eu emocionei
se eu inspirei seu provocar uma reflexão
quando eu vejo que eu fiz isso para
alguém eu me sinto extremamente
realizada e principalmente quando eu
percebo que alguém que consegue
transmitir o meu olhar sobre a vida das
outras pessoas que eu consigo
compartilhar com as pessoas do meu jeito
de levar a vida e isso me dá uma uma
felicidade enorme porque porque eu gosto
de levar a vida com muita leveza
eu acho que existem escolhas que a gente
pode fazer eu vou dar um exemplo aqui
vamos supor que você tem um jantar
marcado com amigos enfim você demora uma
hora de trânsito caótico para chegar lá
aí você chega e você tem duas maneiras
determinasse à noite você pode encontrar
seus amigos
e ficar se lamentando do trânsito e com
certeza eles vão te apoiar nas
reclamações porque tem sempre alguém
louco pra reclamar com você e vai ser
uma noite até rima de lamentação outro
jeito de terminar essa noite
você chegou cansado estressado
esbaforidos respira fundo senta com seus
amigos pede um bom vinho pede um bom
prato
bati um papo gostoso e têm uma noite
super agradável ou seja nós podemos
fazer escolhas
nesses momentos que você faz no dia em
que seu filho acorda numa segunda feira
cedo
cansado exausto gruda na cadeira da sala
e fala hoje eu não vou pra escola
estou cansado não vou como é que você
faz oque ele começou às 4 da manhã
meu filho apareceu com tosse e o
pretexto ideal para cabular aula numa
segunda-feira de um pouco de água
um xarope espirrei óleo essencial de
lavanda no seu travesseiro e espere até
que ele relaxasse dormisse 6 41 dia meu
lindo ea saga começa a mãe não tão bem
mãe não quer ir pra escola
eu falo um pouco convencer outro pouco e
sem resultado apelo para o você vai e
acabou seu olhar baixo paralisado
enquanto gira colher pelo cappuccino
demonstra que o mau humor impera
eu tenho a brilhante idéia de colocar
uma música pra quebrar o clima aperta o
play no telefone e surge fábio júnior
sério diz a essas coisas tudo bem que eu
já fui muito fã de jorge o moço bonito
já tirei foto da televisão porque não
existia google pra poder guardar uma
imagem dele mas eu tinha 12 anos
o marco do rock ele não vai curtir essa
música tiro logo a baladinha romântica
eu procuro útil a beautiful day é tudo
que precisamos e tonta eu nunca tinha
prestado atenção na letra só no refrão
começa a escutar e vejo que é péssima
para o momento ea hora o placar
sem sorte o fmi está aqui transita por
parada e você não vai se mexer para
voltar ao golfe não não é a segunda
começou difícil quieto bono bom hora de
sair como corremos para escovar os
dentes espirro minha base preferida na
esponja e percebo que está nas últimas
gotas até isso mandei glory mandei
entramos no carro ele ainda reclama
porque precisa ir à escola mesmo depois
da noite complicada eu continuo achando
que uma boa música vai nos salvar
ligo o som quem vem
sei que o dalton zangão in to solberg
fios a em menos de uma estrofe já
estamos sorrindo
os instrumentos surgem de diferentes
cantos do carro
as cores do dia fico muito mais intensas
e o clima é de um lindo sonho
psicodélico marcos chama atenção para o
solo pouco ao lado dele mãe
o ringo star do seu lado parece papo de
louco mas ele está certíssimo o baixo
vem pela direita a bateria vem pela
esquerda do carro
vamos de bittles pelo resto do caminho
vamos cantando sobre fields forever
eu gosto de levar a vida com leveza e eu
acho que nos pequenos momentos a gente
pode fazer essa escolha e até nas coisas
um pouco mais chatas
por exemplo se envelhecer é inevitável
porque a gente não pode envelhecer com
bom humor
[Música]
eu já passei dos quarenta e tantos
se você perguntar o número exato eu vou
responder porque tem essa estranha mania
de dizer a verdade
vamos combinar uma coisa melhor você
ficar imaginando que eu imagino que você
imaginou e fica tudo certo idade
complicada essa até agora nada mudou
não me sinto diferente de dez anos atrás
a mesma disposição mesmos gostos mesmo
as implicâncias menos paciência verdade
mais perspicácia menos hipocrisia
mas só faço o que eu quero só vou onde
eu quero agora tem uma coisa que assusta
o momento da passagem porque em algum
pôr-do-sol noite de lua cheia ou
conjunção astral
eu não serei mais considerada uma mulher
jovem e essa mudança acontece assim diz
com passada porque o mundo nos vê
transformados muito antes do que nós
mesmos
um dia desses eu me vi ali na frente do
espelho daquela cena bem clichê de
protagonista madura da novela das nove
eu dava uma esticadinha no rosto sério 4
milímetros equivalem a 10 anos a menos e
fiquei com 35 anos não tudo bem vá eu
não vou mentir já falei a verdade lá na
frente eu não vou é desprezar sua
agilidade na matemática pouquinho mais
de 10
admito que tenha uma relação estranha
com esse misterioso momento da passagem
eu criei uma competição eu contra ele
faço testes diários cada vez que eu
chego em algum lugar moça papelzinho
acho que esqueça de pegar o papel de
propósito só pra ver o manobrista me
chamar precisa de ajuda até o carro moça
os garotos do supermercado são umas
graças a gorjeta caprichada o pão de
queijo vai demorar dez minutos moça vai
esperar
lógico que eu espero quem tem pressa em
são paulo
bom dia a senhora carteirinha do
convênio documento por favor
sim claro mas não precisa me chamar
senhora entende senhora a senhora pode
assinar aqui por favor sim mas não
precisa agora a senhora pode aguardar a
próxima fala que eu posso fazer uma
pergunta alguma dúvida senhora porque
você está me chamando de senhora e por
respeito senhora mas eu falei que não
precisa do costume senhora eu tenho cara
de senhora não senhora
por que esse costume então é o
treinamento senhora
ai que alívio demorou mas ela disse a
palavra mágica treinamento
escapei mais uma vez 253 a 0 pra mim
então é isso depois de vários tombos eu
aprendi que a felicidade não vêem com
hora marcada
então nós temos que estar atentos para
os pequenos momentos de prazer da vida
como aquele dia que você estava indo
para uma reunião deu de cara com uma
feira parou e comer um pastel às 11 da
manhã não foi uma delícia mas você
reparou nisso então os momentos de
prazer precisam ser garimpadas e assim a
nossa vida fica muito mais gostosa
porque a vida tem que ser vivida
experimentada disfruta da em todas as
suas sutilezas
afinal de contas a vida é o que fazemos
dela
[Aplausos]